[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here today i'm going to
explain an american science fiction
comedy film called the nutty professor
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the story revolves around an overweight
and clumsy science professor named
sherman klump he is well liked by his
students and peers but his clumsiness
gets him into a lot of trouble one
morning he walks to his work at the
wellman college to see it being overrun
by more than 5 000 hamsters the
infestation grows so bad that the
rodents start getting inside people's
pants and into their sandwiches causing
chaos everywhere the animals are lab
hamsters who were somehow let free on
investigating it is discovered that the
previous day sherman's protruding belly
hit a button that opened the cages
without him knowing when the problem is
contained sherman goes to his favorite
experimental hamster shelly who is also
overweight sherman and his team have
been experimenting with a formula that
reconstructs the dna of an obese person
to make them lose weight easily and
quickly the serum was used on shelley
and the results say that the hamster
lost three ounces in only a day this
proves the efficiency of the product to
find out more about its nature sherman's
lab assistant jason suggests increasing
the amount shelley is fed but sherman
thinks it could be dangerous for the
animal after that he is called to the
dean's office to discuss the incident
with the hamsters sherman is informed
that because of the incident the science
department has lost most of its funding
a man named harlan is the school's last
remaining alumnus who is planning to
donate 10 million dollars to the college
the dean warns clump to be careful with
his experiments because they are not in
the position to lose their last alumnus
during class sherman's protruding belly
rubs off the board much to his students
amusement he notices it and laughs with
them after that a new teacher named miss
carla comes to greet him she is a
chemistry graduate teaching a class
across the hall sherman is instantly
smitten by her beauty and kindness she
reveals she is a huge fan of his work
and has always wanted to meet him later
that day sherman meets his family for
dinner all of whom are overweight he
recognizes that they have a problem but
his father takes pride in being fat and
unhealthy after noticing sherman takes
small amounts of food from the table his
father claims that he can do everything
in the world but losing weight is not
one of them the man also has a very bad
habit of randomly passing gas to the
point where he defecates himself
although sherman finds it absolutely
disgusting his father does the procedure
religiously and in front of his family
when he leaves to clean his pants
sherman's mother anna senses that he is
hurt by his father's words she makes him
feel better by declaring that he is
beautiful inside out sherman is
motivated by her words to ask miss carla
out on a date right after he goes to her
house to do so and to his surprise she
accepts immediately they decide to go to
a place named the scream on friday
sherman returns home with the biggest
smile on his face he dances around
overjoyed about finally landing a date
with someone he likes while watching tv
he falls asleep and dreams of making out
with carla on a beach but while they are
at it she gets buried in the sand by his
weight sherman wakes up in horror to the
host of the tv show yelling yes i can he
repeats the words and is motivated to
lose weight one way or the other for the
next few days leading up to the date
sherman goes to zumba classes the gym
and acupuncture sessions but he still
has a lot of work to do to reach his
ultimate goal the couple goes to a club
on friday and has a great time for the
first half of the date but then an
insult comic named reggie comes to the
stage for a stand-up comedy show he
makes fun of the audience's appearance
one after another when he gets to
sherman the comedian gets an easy target
he drags sherman down to filth with his
insults so much so that sherman gets
teary after the performance following
the awful date sherman takes carla home
to make him feel better she tells him
that he is a brilliant man sherman
thanks her and returns home disheartened
alone and depressed he starts to binge
on junk food disregarding all the
progress he has made in the gym for the
past week eventually he dozes off and
has a nightmare about having a heart
attack on the hospital bed he grows into
a giant and breaks out into the world
his single fart destroys the city and
wakes him up from the nightmare sherman
now has had enough of his obesity he
knows that if he relies on exercise and
healthy food he will give in to the
temptation every time so he decides to
use his lab serum on himself at midnight
he goes to the lab prepares the medicine
and injects himself with it initially
the experiment is a disaster as the
computer glitches and his heart rate
increases when sherman passes out a
message displays on the screen saying
that the dna reconstruction was a
success
the next morning sherman wakes up and is
startled when he looks in the mirror he
has become a fit young man unlike
himself from the previous night he
almost cries on seeing that he went from
cup c to cup a and cannot believe his
eyes to see his genitals for the first
time in years unable to control his joy
he runs outside shouting to the world to
look at him the first place he goes is
the shopping mall spandex section as you
do he wears clothes that complement his
body and models in front of the mirror
the following day he is working in the
lab when carla comes looking for sherman
she doesn't recognize him because of
obvious reasons sherman also doesn't
want her to look at him as the old
overweight person that he was hence he
invents a random name buddy love and
introduces himself as a lab assistant he
also flirts with her and asks her out on
a date to the club initially carla is
reluctant but she agrees to go when he
persists as they talk sherman's fingers
start to swell indicating that he's
about to retransform to his older self
he quickly excuses himself before she
catches him blowing up later carla meets
sherman and tells him about buddy's
proposal sherman encourages her to go
and pitches on how good of a man buddy
is in the following scene buddy arrives
at the club in a sports car that he
would have never been able to fit in
prior to the transformation he and carla
enter the club together as per usual
reggie is welcomed to the stage for a
show this time a confident buddy throws
insults back at the comedian giving him
a taste of his own medicine by the end
of the night they get into a yo mama
joke battle that buddy wins an enraged
reggie tries to attack him for stealing
the show but is in turn slammed into the
piano the crowd cheers for buddy along
with unimpressed carla they share a kiss
and a romantic moment together but right
after buddy's bottom lip starts to swell
he makes an excuse about it being an
allergic reaction and rushes outside at
the same time sherman's lab assistant
jason happens to be at the bar he
notices a waiter handling sherman's card
but is told that the card belongs to
buddy he assumes that buddy stole the
professor's card and follows him to his
car to jason's surprise he catches
sherman mid-transformation with a
heavily swollen lip and expanding legs
when he is fully transformed the
assistant realizes what is going on
later sherman has to be cut out of the
car when he becomes too big to use the
door the next morning sherman is very
late for a class because of an
uneventful night all the students have
already left but an angry dean is
waiting for him he confronts sherman
about the sports car which buddy bought
on sherman's faculty account the dean
forgives him for the extravagant spend
but threatens to strangle him to death
if he messes up one more time he has set
up a meeting between sherman and the
college's alumnus hartley sherman has to
convince hartley to fund the weight loss
serum project that he is working on
later sherman meets carla and asks her
about the date with buddy she seems to
be confused if she likes him and is
unsettled by his behavior sherman
dismisses the conversation and asks her
out on a second date to dinner with his
family why would he do that she happily
agrees and meets them all at his parents
house the family asks her intrusive
questions about their relationship most
of it relating to sex carla is visibly
uncomfortable which adds up when
sherman's father repeatedly farts after
the disastrous dinner sherman walks
carla home and apologizes on behalf of
his family carla wants to know more
about buddy and is hoping that he will
call her back sherman realizes that he
can only be with her as buddy and
transforms into him once again his
assistant jason is not happy about the
transformation every time sherman takes
the serum buddy's testosterone level
rises exponentially making him rowdy
unlike sherman if this continues for a
long time buddy might take over
sherman's body as a new man jason tries
to stop him but buddy tricks him and
runs away that night he lands a date
with carla yet again and takes her to a
hotel at the same hotel harlan is
waiting for him to present the weight
loss serum idea for the sake of the
college carla wants him to take
sherman's place and pitch the idea to
the alumnus but he does is told and
explains the serum to him by sexualizing
the girls at the restaurant and flirting
with them he takes all the credit for
sherman's work which carla thinks is
outrageous but he doesn't care about
what she thinks because all he wants is
to be with a girl carla storms off after
he dismisses her for the other girls
the dean gives sherman's position to
buddy and asks him to give a final
demonstration for harlan at the alumni
ball the following night buddy spends
the rest of the night wildly partying
with several women by the morning he is
transferred to sherman and is confused
as to how he is with the women on the
bed buddy's presence is harming
sherman's memory and rationality almost
as if he has a multiple personality
disorder carla arrives shortly
thereafter and finds sherman with the
girls she thinks sherman is just as
unfaithful as buddy to the extent that
the two of them share women following
that sherman goes to the office to find
out that the dean has fired him and
given his position to his alter ego
buddy sherman doesn't know what he
should do next at home he accidentally
activates the vcr and finds out that
buddy has left a message for him last
night in the message he taunts sherman
about his boring life and urges him to
take the serum and change himself
forever the taunt only motivates him to
destroy the serum altogether and never
let buddy surface again he and jason go
to the lab and start destroying all the
serum samples sherman takes a sip from a
diet drink unaware that buddy had filled
it with the serum knowing that he could
be in danger of vanishing because of the
trick sherman turns into buddy again and
runs to the alumni ball after he leaves
jason sees the computer flashing a
warning message that says buddy's
testosterone levels are at a lethal high
if he takes the serum again he may kill
sherman altogether and buddy will
permanently exist in his place meanwhile
buddy makes a grand entrance to the ball
catching everyone's attention he
immediately begins to demonstrate the
effects of the serum to the stunned
audience his half-bulked-up body
surprises everyone as he is about to
drink the second dose of serum to end
sherman forever jason arrives and stops
him but his arm suddenly bulks up and
tries to choke himself it turns out that
the arm is sherman fighting for the
rights to his own body eventually buddy
is unable to take the serum on time and
transforms back into sherman everyone in
the audience including carla and his
parents are in shock sherman explains
that the experiment was initiated to
help people but it turned into something
that it shouldn't have he has come to
terms with the fact that he should
accept himself whilst trying to work
harder for a healthier body thinking
that he has been a disappointment to
everyone he attempts to leave but is
stopped by carla she asks him to a dance
proving that she liked him for his inner
self not his body in the last scene we
see them dancing all night hartley
decides to give sherman the donation
claiming that he was touched by his
speech and although the experiment
failed he is a brilliant scientist
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching